so
we broke a rule
yeah
i hope it wasn't a mistake
hope it wasn't a mistake title your sex
tape
title of our sex tape
all right what i am about to say will
make you very horny but you have to try
and remember that we're still at work
do you want me to quiz you oh god yes
wow okay great so this is a brine barrel
it's made by josiah wooldriff who
learned the craft from his father jessia
wooldriff who in turn learned you know
what this was a terrible idea i'm sorry
don't you dare stop oh
okay uh josiah's cousin joshua was a
cooper not a hooper oh mama i told you
i'll always be one step ahead of you you
can't surprise me you're boring you know
what spices up a relationship co-owning
a multi-tiered marketing ignore him look
there are three tramps the only way
we're gonna win is if we team up good
point
i guess my response is
rotten hell crap-face also i love you
and i treasure you and you bore me god
you're being so mean
do it more i hope you die
bye
captain holt is here today yes genius he
loves us and he's got tons of sway in
the department he'll tell the vulture to
back down yeah he'll be all vulture i
must insist that you desist i really
think this is gonna work
also if you ever want to bust out that
whole impression at home i'd be okay
with that oh
okay duly noted super disturbing but i'm
definitely gonna do it
look there's the buyer
or maybe he's just actually saying hi to
the chef why isn't he making the handoff
oh crap he saw us
excuse me
oh hey we were just
looking for a place to uh boink
yep
boink that's my preferred term for it as
well
i get it newly engaged kids
enjoy
good good good good kept our cover in
tech nice work quick professional
thinking out there very quick very
professional detective detective
back on the case
light off the captain that man is gonna
be my rabbi okay first of all when you
use the word rabbi you know that turns
me on and that's unfair in the work
environment you're not leaving this room
what the hell is going on i can't let
you quit yes but why the candles and
rose petals
whoa is that mr mclean i hear cause
someone's about to die oh my god why is
captain hold here because he's gonna
wait
are you dressed like bonnie bedelia and
die hard i am for sexy reasons yes oh
boy jake why is he here because he's
quitting the force so i brought him here
to convince him not to but obviously
that is not important anymore all right
captain it's been a good run thank you
for teaching me the importance of a tie
in the workplace and the door's right
over here you are looking good really
kind of feel like i'm jimmy buffett's
tennis coach no it's working you know i
had a major crush on magnum p.i
major oh should i grow a mustache yeah
you should actually i can't i'm
physically incapable i shouldn't have
suggested that should we go in okay i've
got something oh that's not brandon's
profile it's mine i just want a quick
peek at your attendance record zero
absences
oh mama printing this for later keep it
in your pants santiago oh that's exactly
where it's going
okay here's brandon's info third period
for semester any of these people on the
football team scott alford taylor black
wow tom brady different tom brady he was
in theater although he was the mvp of
that year's production of fiddler
wait a minute danny mathews that's the
guy he was on the football team that's
the bastard who set me up yeah and look
at this
you did so much community service
me likey
i am straight up depressed amy's been
doing her best to cheer me up she gave
me the sticker this morning just for
waking up yeah it's like you're dating
your teacher i know it's so hot
okay i just won't ever open it that way
i'll never get rejected fine i'll open
it no no no no
i opened it
happy oh yeah you look like every girl
at every bat mitzvah i ever had a crush
on
let's see the bow
just like jenny gildenhorn why do i wish
you had braces should we get you braces
no that's too much
wow she is great at shushing i know
she's like a librarian me like a sexy
librarian no
a regular one okay it's time to
celebrate you know what that means this
bee needs a c in her a oh my god this
babe needs a coconut in her arms oh
i thought you were saying this music
oh my god yeah that was my reaction all
right i'll go get us a couple of
coconuts guys you know i'm actually a
little bit hungry i never ended up
eating at that dumb fancy restaurant
know what i'm getting on my way home
yeah you're gonna go to the polish place
and get pierogies potato pancakes and a
cup of hot chocolate
that's exactly what i'm gonna get
i will be having pizza two slices of
meat supreme from tony served display
temperature meat supreme is a million
red flags and eating it cold is just
insane no it's not cold it's display
temperature there's a difference amy no
jake he's looking at us
well this is happening huh
[Music]
nypd we are police colleagues you're
under arrest this is a work event i love
you i love you
[Music]
should we go yes okay
what else oh you're never gonna believe
this i've been reading reading like
books by real authors i don't know is
philip roth a real author oh my goodness
i wish you had gone to prison years ago
i'm kidding obviously i'm not more
attracted to you now than before
okay you ready
hello oh my god
are you melville dewey indeed i am
i invented the dewey decimal system but
right now i'm working on
the do me decimal system mm-hmm yeah
this is really working for me really
yeah awesome so mr dewey can you save me
from the terrorists that have taken over
nakatomi plaza yes holly gennaro
i just need to file them in the library
card catalog yeah this is really hard to
track let's just take our clothes off oh
thank god this old jacket is so hot yeah
so lieutenant sorry to take up your time
i just wanted to go over the comp set
numbers with you real quick
um what the is something wrong are the
comp stat numbers back
the numbers are fine and i have to go oh
okay then why'd you ask for this me
don't follow me terry what i wasn't
going to this was a very confusing
interaction
hello hello sergeant santiago i've taken
your husband hostage if you ever want to
make a baby with him you'll do exactly
as i say jake where are you oh this is a
jake this is the syndicate and you will
never see us because we are everywhere
you're by the elevators damn it look
away look away okay yes that's better on
top of the copier there's a headset put
it on and get in the limo that's waiting
out front okay i love you i love you too
now go
are you amy tell him yes yes how does it
feel to be played like a puppet
okay i'm walking into the apartment
why did you have me get 400 out of the
atm good question it's to pay for the
airbnb you're giving them 400 in cash i
broke several lamps while trying to hide
in the dark now turn on the lights
hello it's me put down the drinks why
are you upset yeah and now i have to
take the syndicate down oh my goodness
to be clear if i take down the syndicate
you mean we're gonna we're gonna have
sex absolutely take your clothes off
you